>> Let me thank
all of you for holding
on so long all day.
This is really amazing,
the room was full at 9:00
AM and it's still
pretty full now.
It's amazing in
this horrible weather.
I really loved the day because I
think I know this
was the panel that was
called the future,
but I think in essence,
all of it was about the future.
I think that talking about
theory as Robert Douglas panel
did about the beauty,
about these ideas that
we find and we follow,
and that resonate and give
us new ways of looking
at the world on how they
pay off on anticipated ways
as the gems that they are
thinking will always do.
And then, second panel
on machine learning
which now are so much hype around
machine learning but there's also
so much promise and
so many questions.
I think for us, yes
there are so many applications
of machine learning
that we have yet to see in
the healthcare domain and
in so many other domains,
but I think again we're
going to find that strand of
beauty we don't yet
understand why it works,
and I think that will bring those
of us who love
theory and those of
us who care deeply about
the social good that
can come out of
machine learning together.
We're really just at
the very beginning
of machine learning.
Then, I guess we had
the panel on platforms
which I found amazing,
from scholars who really
study platforms with
their two new books
which were amazing to
someone who's the Chief
Economist for one of
the biggest platforms
in the world and
one that is most functional
due to the fact that it
came with its own set
of social norms,
which was really a blessing
for LinkedIn, right?
The other ones were
the norms, who knows?
With Bridget on it,
how many millions of
followers do she have?
Four point six million followers,
I mean, just amazing.
And I love the fact that
she's back in grad school.
As she creates this following,
she's studying this following,
and to me that was just amazing.
Then the Fate panel,
Hannah's Fate panel, fairness,
accountability, transparency,
and ethics, which I
think is one of the most
important developments
of the past decade that we want
to find ways to rather
than having AI compound
the injustices,
make things less interpretable,
rather than doing that,
having AI help us
ultimately to make decisions
that are fairer than
human judgments,
but we must define what
we mean by fairness,
which is why we must work
with legal scholars,
and ethicists, and philosophers.
Then finally, this panel
which as you can see,
I stacked with people who
don't make wild predictions of
the future but who ground us
and provide motivations
for that path.
We should be looking
towards taking
all these other things into,
I mean I just love this lab.
I love MSR in general and really,
I am deeply indebted to Microsoft
for supporting us in doing
this kind of research.
I think because we're pretty
smart so we figure out
ways to make this pay off for
the company because we live
in a world of incentives,
but it's just an
additional constraint,
we want to do great things,
create great social good,
and also make
this a good proposition
so that other companies
will do this.
As I say, just another
constraint and
the unconstrained life
is not worth living.
So, thank you everyone.
Oh my god,
and there are two people
I need to thank them.
Sit down there because
you are one of them.
Nicole Emerlita and her committee
put together
this amazing program.
One thing that's
happened to me as I
get one more labs to manage,
one more jobs that
I have to let go,
and I don't want to let go
the people who are amazing,
and I let go
the planning of this to
Nicole who did an amazing job
and to Lauren who's
back there who
doesn't like to be called
out but there she is,
who just did a spectacular job.
I only trust
brilliant perfectionist
and both of you are
brilliant perfectionists.
>> Thank you so much Jennifer.
It was a great pleasure to share
this wonderful day with all
of you and I'm quite pleased.
We could give a round of applause
to all of our panelists
that I think
we chose very well right now.
There is now a reception
from 5-7 with a live band.
There's going to be
a little surprise around 5:30
I think so stick
around, it'll be great.